[Music]
what it do everybody
merry holidays my name is ross panetta
chef and owner of five kitchen
today we are here to test out four
celebrity
cookie recipes to see which one is the
jolliest we have taylor swift
mariah carey melania trump and jessica
alba
i measured out all the ingredients as
each recipe stated i got three cookie
enthusiasts
to come test them out to see which one
is their favorite so which celebrity has
the best holiday cookie recipe
how to make it rain deer let's get it so
first up we have taylor swift's cookie
recipe you're gonna cream together
butter
sugar egg vanilla and oil until it's all
nice and mixed
make sure to move we're going to throw
in our baking soda
salt and her little secret chai tea
once the batter has come together we're
going to slowly add our flour and
increments
until the batter is nice and smooth
[Music]
now that your cookie dough is formed
we're gonna put in the refrigerator for
about an hour or in the freezer for up
to 15 minutes
once the dough is nice and set we're
gonna divide it throw some flour on the
board flour on our rolling pin so it
doesn't stick
and we're gonna roll it out to about a
quarter inch thickness
your favorite cookie cutter make sure to
keep it festive now like i did
and cut out some shapes
[Music]
on a lined baking tray we're going to
place the cookies about two inches apart
and bake at 350 degrees
until nice and golden brown we're gonna
put together the eggnog icing
in a bowl cinnamon nutmeg a little bit
of eggnog
a lot of powdered sugar
[Music]
the icing was looking a little bit thick
here so i added a little bit more eggnog
to reach the consistency that i wanted
once the cookies come out of the oven
we're going to ice the top of the
cookies
with the eggnog icing and just a dash of
cinnamon on top for a little bit of
flavor
[Music]
and there you have it taylor swift's
chai tea eggnog cookie
what is this this is a beautiful color i
love a little brown on brown
uh cookie looks like a gingerbread
cookie maybe of sorts
some cinnamon for sure a little weight
to it that's always good
mmm that's nice it's a crispy cookie
personally i'm more of a i like a little
bit of softness in a cookie but but this
isn't too
hard it tastes kind of like those like
biscotti cookies a little bit but
elevated i feel like i'm more into like
the chewy cookies
but i really like the cinnamon whoever
made this one
i guess really enjoys the holidays it
really knows how to spice things
up i could see myself eating like 100 of
these and forgetting that i was eating
anything
so probably not give me more of them
next up we have mariah carey's cookie
recipe in a bowl we're going to cream
together butter and sugar
until it's light and fluffy
once that's done we're going to add an
egg milk
lemon zest vanilla and we're going to
mix that up until it's nice and smooth
we're going to add baking soda salt and
once again add flour and increments
until you reach a nice consistency
[Music]
once the dough is finished we're going
to bring it together and wrap it up in
plastic
and refrigerate it for about 15 minutes
to a half hour
now that we're ready to roll out flour
the board and flour rolling pin so it
doesn't stick
we're going to roll this dough out to
about an eighth of an inch thickness
since mariah carey is the queen of
christmas i cut these out in christmas
tree shapes
once again on a lined baking sheet
spread them out about two inches apart
and bake until golden brown
once the cookies come out the oven ice
to your heart's desire do not
add me i'm having fun kind of
once you're done icing the cookies throw
a little red and green sprinkles on that
thing
and plate it up mariah carey's holiday
sugar cookie recipe
this is cute got some fun sprinkles
very sparsely uh sprinkled though if i'm
making cookies i just kind of go ham on
the sprinkles
i want to be everywhere
whenever you drool that's a good sign
okay it reminds me of like those
animal crackers kind of yeah this one's
definitely a bit drier
than i would like i mean yeah this is
like your regular
sugar cookie just a little bland if it's
a sugar cookie
where's the sugar with something that's
dry you either need to make it a little
softer or you need to add
like a lot more frosting i'll still
finish the cookie though so
step it up celebs and next up we have
melania trump's sugar cookie recipe
in a bowl we're going to combine flour
and baking soda set that aside
in another bowl we're going to combine
butter sugar egg yolk
egg white and cream that together until
it's nice and smooth once that comes to
a nice consistency we're going to add in
our sour cream
vanilla salt we're going to mix that up
until it's fully incorporated
once again working in increments we're
going to slowly add our flour until the
dough forms
once the dough is formed we're going to
wrap it up and throw it in the fridge
for about 15 minutes to a half hour
once again flour your board apply your
rolling pin so it doesn't stick and
we're going to roll this out to about a
quarter inch thickness
she used stars and i use plains to cut
out my cookies because you know she's
about to get out of there
and on a lined cookie tray place it
about two inches apart
and bake it at 350 degrees once again
ice to your heart's desire
i suck at icing things as you can see
[Music]
and there you have it melania trump's
sugar cookie recipe
is this a plane quite possibly an angel
like a dove or an airplane
not super sure oh
this kind of tastes like the crust on a
pie but some people
enjoy that type of taste i don't
maybe the icing's a little bit more
flavorful nothing really special to me
that one just crumbled apart
it was nice it wasn't super sweet but
it's easy to chew through these
it's kind of like a little cracker so
like this one was pretty good
and next up we have america's favorite
crush jessica alba
in a bowl we're going to combine
together coconut oil powdered sugar
vanilla almond milk and mix that up
until a batter has formed
we're going to throw in some corn starch
and mix that up until it gets a little
bit thicker
and lastly working in increments once
again throw in your flour
and mix until a very loose sandy dough
is formed
if the dough is looking a little too dry
you can add more milk and bring it to
the consistency that you want it to be
we're going to wrap it up in some
plastic and throw it in the fridge and
let it harden for about an hour or two
once your dough is ready to be rolled
out go ahead and flour your surface
flour your rolling pin we're going to
roll it out to about a quarter inch
thickness
once again choose whatever shape you
want i chose an angel because you
already know she looks like one
and on a lime baking tray spread it out
about two inches apart
we're gonna bake these at 375 degrees or
until golden brown
and there you have it ladies and
gentlemen jessica alba's vegan sugar
cookie recipe
enjoy this one looks like someone died
it looks very dry
i mean i guess cookies are supposed to
be dry but this is a ashy cookie
why is there a crunch oh god
what was that i didn't know something
could be impossible to chew through but
also
chewy is this like a health cookie i'm
really confused
this like hurts my teeth like biting it
it's like
picking up a brick and starting to to
bite it in spite of the difficulty of
chewing through this like
if you don't want too much sugar but you
still want a little treat
the flavor from this could could do you
for that this isn't it
i'm sorry do i get a free dive just
after this
so which celebrity has the best holiday
recipe let's find out
out of these four celebrity holiday
cookie recipes
my favorite has to be number one
because it was bold it wasn't scared to
throw in those extra flavors
the texture was good the sweetness level
was
high teite i guess she just got a new
fan
my favorite would actually have to be
number three i think
i actually really liked how thin and
crunchy it was i thought it was
like a nice kind of subtle treat whose
was that
melania trump
[Laughter]
maybe melania is a better baker than i
would have anticipated i never pictured
melania trump baking
but surprised there wasn't like gold
leaf on it
i think i'm gonna have to go with number
one definitely the one i enjoyed the
most i liked the cinnamon
the icing on top was nice okay
i respect that i think i think she did a
good job good job taylor
taylor swift takes today's celebrity
holiday cookie
challenge let us know which holiday
cookie was your favorite
leave a comment below